[Music]
thank you all for joining us my name is
Mike Connolly I'm a new state
representative for cambridge and
somerville thank you
[Applause]
last year I was one of just two
candidates to actually defeat an
incumbent for a seat in the state
legislature and I did it with the help
of mass piece action so thank you for
your support I just want to talk a
little bit about you know what called me
to public service what led to my getting
involved with public service and how the
topic under discussion today around
ending nuclear proliferation and really
ending militarism more broadly is so
essential to everything else that I'm
trying to accomplish
in the state legislature so I was born
in Dorchester my parents divorced when I
was about five my mother and I moved to
public housing in Norwood Massachusetts
I benefited from things like head start
as a kid but as you can see I'm a giant
I was good on the football field I got a
full athletic scholarship to Duke
University and then after that I came
back to the BC law became an attorney
and along the way you know growing up in
public housing it was instilled in me
really that the Democratic Party would
be the party that would fight for anyone
who faced a difficulty in life but as
the years went by and as I saw the
profound wealth and income inequality in
our world as I looked at you know the
influence of money on our political
system I really thought it was important
that we as Democrats and we as people on
the Left do a lot more to engage our
political system and try to make sure
that our party and our government live
up to those values that really sustains
me when I was growing up so that was
really you know what called me into
public service I had an opportunity to
work on things like affordable housing
and sustainability here in Cambridge and
that all culminated with
a huge grassroots campaign there were
literally hundreds of volunteers in our
community who supported me in various
ways knocking on doors making phone
calls to help us win our election last
year the gentleman I defeated had
actually won 38 elections in a row prior
to our victory so it was it was a
shocker
for some so thank you all in the room
who helped us on this struggle so now
I'm at the Statehouse and I'm fighting
for a bold progressive agenda I'm proud
to say that I would call it a democratic
socialist agenda I'm fighting for a $15
minimum wage paid family medical leave
single-payer health care Medicare for
all Thank You congresswoman fair
applause on that I'm fighting for
affordable housing I think that this
idea that we had of public housing in
our country we're kind of losing it I
think we should actually go back to
raising revenue and saying let's put
these funds into building the housing so
I'm fighting for public housing I'm
fighting for affordable housing I'm
fighting for criminal justice reform 2nz
yeah thank you
to end the to end the racist war on
drugs and to end mandatory minimum
sentencing which I'm sorry to say we
still have here in our Commonwealth to a
far too great of an extent and one final
thing I'm fighting for the Safe
Communities Act which would make us a
sanctuary state so that we don't lose
sight of the fact that we're a nation of
immigrants so those are some of the
things I'm fighting for but you know I
think it really struck me when I saw the
flier for the event and how this event
coincides with the 50th anniversary of
dr. Martin Luther King's beyond Vietnam
Street speech which is also known as a
time to break the silence and in that
speech dr. King said how difficult it
really is for any of us whether we're in
government or whether we're just you
know activists acting on our own as
citizens how difficult it really is to
and up to the war machine to stand up to
the military into the these imperialist
notions that have always been a part of
our country you know there are some
people who said that when dr. King gave
that speech It was as if he was signing
his own death warrant and he faced a lot
of criticism for giving that speech but
I just want to quote one paragraph
because I think it's so important to
what we're talking about today he said
I'm convinced that if we are to get on
the right side of the world revolution
we as a nation must undergo a radical
revolution of values we must rapidly
begin to shift from a thing oriented
society to a person oriented society he
said that when machines and computers
profit motives and property rights are
considered more important than people
than the giant Triplets of racism
materialism and militarism are incapable
of being conquered and it's you know
it's just amazing how those words are so
prophetic and how they they ring just as
true today forty-nine years later as
they did when he delivered that speech
in New York City on April 4th 1967 and
you know I think as I think about you
know these progressive movements that
I'm involved in and I think about the
campaign's that have been you know I
think that we've given some really good
voice those of us on the left to issues
of income and wealth inequality I was
part of the Occupy Wall Street movement
and there was a time where this idea is
inequality really you know really wasn't
on the radar and today it's on
everyone's radar even Donald Trump as a
candidate would talk about inequality
even though his policies would do
nothing but make it worse you know on
the topic of racism and white supremacy
we clearly have so much more work to do
but there are movements like black lives
matter that are engaging people in our
community and that are really elevating
this discussion in a positive way and it
gives us a path forward as we try to
continue to deal with the legacy of
racism and
can you to fight white supremacy that's
represented by Donald Trump and that is
all too common all over our country but
then when it comes to that third triplet
that third evil triplet that dr. King
spoke about forty-nine years ago
militarism and imperialism I'm afraid
that you know those of us on the Left
have so much more work to do to give
voice to that concern for our generation
and so that's why thank you that's why
I'm so you know happy to be here be a
part of this so you know one of the ways
that we can really address you know the
role of military in our budget is this
people's budget campaign and we just had
a workshop a little while ago where we
talked a bit about the people's budget
it's really a road map for resistance
and it's powerful because it provides a
positive alternative it's not just
saying we are opposed to this we don't
want that it's saying here's what we
could have in particular if we you know
didn't commit some 54% of our
discretionary budget as Professor King
pointed out to the military if we were
able to dial that back to a more
reasonable posture what are all the
other things that we could do we could
have affordable housing we could have
health care as a human right we could
have pre-k just like I had a head start
program I ask why isn't it that every
child in our state and in our country
cannot have all of the early education
all of the childcare all of the public
education all the way through college
and grad school that they could possibly
need we could have all those things if
we adopted a piece of people's budget
I'll say a few words about our own state
budget
I'm glad we're joined by my colleague
rep Provo from Somerville and we work
very closely in the Statehouse really
trying to tackle issues in our own state
budget so there's a fact that I want to
share with you our state budget is about
3.5 billion dollars less today than it
was 17 years ago when you adjust for
inflation and that's not an anomaly
over the past two decades or so we have
under invested by about fifty billion
dollars here in our Commonwealth and
that is because we had a series of tax
cuts about 17 20 years ago on income tax
on dividends and interest on corporate
tax rates we cut taxes across the board
and we have lost tens of billions of
dollars of investment right here in
democratic Massachusetts where we have a
super majority of Democrats in our
legislature we still cannot find the
momentum or the willingness to actually
raise the revenue we need to fund the
MBTA to fund public housing and
affordable housing to fund all of the
things we need to continue to be a
Commonwealth that we all love and
appreciate thank you so you know I would
just you know stand here to say that you
know as a new state representative as
you know a member and a supporter of
this organization I would just you know
ask us all to continue to echo this call
that dr. King gave some 49 years ago and
to understand that to address any one of
these three giant evils whether it's the
militarism whether it's the materialism
or whether it is the racism to address
any one of these three evils it's going
to mean that we tackle all three head-on
because they're all interconnected and
it's going to be impossible for us to
really have the kind of progressive
society we want if we allow you know
this nuclear weapons or the this
military budget to continue the way it
has so that's what I'm looking forward
to do I'm really grateful to join all of
you today and I'm looking forward to
hearing the congresswoman speak soon and
I'm looking forward to many more fights
and victories in the months and years to
come so thank you for having me
okay
[Music]